في ابلكيشن جديد اسمه لمسه اي اي وطبعا
ظهر من ايام من غير سابق انذار شفنا الناس
من حول العالم وفجاه مغرقين الانستغرام
بالصور اللي بينتجها هذا التطبيق هو هذا
التطبيق للصور ولا تظبيطها وتعديل عليها
لكن المميز اللي في اللي انتشرت بشكل كبير
هي ببساطه انه المشترك بيدفع اربع دولارات
تقريبا وبصور حاله 10 او 20 صوره سيلفي
بزوايا مختلفه والابليكيشن بعدين بيعمل
مجموعه كبيره من الصور المعروفه الان باسم
افاتار يعني ببساطه صور كرتونيه لشخصيته
خلال 20 ل 40 دقيقه بالكثير الابراج
السحريه بتكون جاهزه التطبيق بيستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي وعمل او عمل النجاح
وانتشار مش طبيعي حول العالم
احنا عم نحكي يعني اكثر من اربع مليون
تحميل لتطبيق من اول هذا الشهر يعني من 10
ايام فقط واكثر من ثمانيه تمام يا اما
مليون دولار اندفعوا على هذا التطبيق طبعا
هذا انتشار مش طبيعي وعم عملوا التطبيق
مثل ما قلنا او ذكرنا او هو هذا التطبيق
اذا بتتذكر مشاهدينا بتذكرنا بتطبيق اسمه
فيس اب انتشر بشكل كبير من حوالي ثلاث
سنين وهو برده تطبيق لا تعديل الصور وقتها
كانت الناس بتحط صورها والتطبيق بيتخيل
كيف راح يكون شكلهم في مراحل الشيخوخه
عموما مثل ما صار مع فيس ايضا شفناه شكله
راح يصير مع لانسر فورا ظهرت سيل من
التحضيرات المتعلقه بالخصوصيه واللي بتقول
انه بمجرد تحميل التطبيق والموافقه على
شروطه المستخدم بيعطي الموافقه انه يستخدم
صوره ويبيعها كمان لشركات ثانيه في ناس
حتى بتحضر انه او تحضيراتها بتروح ابعد من
هيك وبتقول انه اصلا كل التطبيقات هاي ما
هي الا مصيده لا الناس في الشباك ولتجميع
بياناتهم احنا على كل حال راح نعود لضيفنا
عبد العزيز الحمادي لنحكي عن هذا الموضوع
عبد العزيز هل التحضيرات فيما يتعلق
بلنساي اي اي في مكانها ام انه يعني
تحذيرات ليست بجديده وبنقدرش نقول انها
خاصه بهذا التطبيق يعني دون عن تطبيقات
اخرى كنا بنستعملها
ومعلوماتنا صارت وين مكان اصلا
الظاهر
بالعكس التحذير جدا منها ومن امثالها من
التطبيقات وذكرتي همم راويه ما حصل فعليا
مع تطبيق حساب المواطن الفعليه قام
باستخدام عدد هائل منصور همم الملايين
المستخدمين حول حول العالم لو عدنا الى
تطبيق
مفهوم الذكاء الاصطناعي هو لا يصبح دقيق
الذكاء الاصطناعي الا بحجم البيانات الذي
التي يقوم بتجميعها فاذا كان عنده عدد
هائل من الصور الملايين وربما مليارات من
الصور في النهايه سيصبح هذا التطبيق ادق
واكثر قدره على التخيل والاستفاده عفوا
افاده ال- المستقيمين بطبيعه الحال انا
همم يعني لو حلف تطبيق همم
على المصحف وعلى اي همم كتاب اخر همم
سيستخدمه الصور ولن يصدقوا في هذا الامر
ولذلك انه يحذر يعني لو كتبوا بالبطل
العريض لانه لن يق هو باستخدام هذه الصوره
وانها سيتم حذفها لن يسلقوا في هذا الامر
لانه هذه الصور تعتبر قيمه عاليه بشكل
كبير جدا لهم ولن يستطيعوا الاستمرار الا
اذا استحوذوا على هذه السوره
او بتحذر من انه ممكن يستخدم صورنا
ويبيعوها لشركات ثانيه طب في تطبيقات كثير
احنا بنستعملها منها تويتر انستغرام كثير
من تطبيقات ال- ال- التواصل الاجتماعي ما
هي بتستخدم صورنا طب احنا شو بعرفنا انه
ما عم يبيعوها او يستخدموها باي شكل احنا
ما بنرضى عنه
الرفع الصور الشخصيه او اي صور على اي
خدمه الكترونيه سيتم استخدامها الفرق ماذا
الفرق انك لو رفعتيه على تويتر انت عارفه
انه هو اصبح منشور على تويتر لو رفعتيه
على السناب شات لو عرفتي رفعتيه على غيره
لكن بعض التطبيقات الشخص يقوم باستخدامها
ويتوقع انه هذه الصور ستبقى داخل التطبيق
فلذلك يقوم بمشاركه اشياء خاصه اشياء
يتوقع انه ما يتم نشرها وما يتم فعليا همم
الاستفاده منها لكن همم نحن نبين لا سيتم
الاستفاده من ذلك الخطر في هذه التطبيقات
اعلى بشكل كبير مقارنه بتطبيقات اخرى مثل
مثل تويتر فلذلك بمثلها التطبيق هاي هاي
سيقوم بجمع ملايين الصور والمستثمارها
بنقول للناس اللي بده يستخدم
انه الصور اللي بيبعثها بيرسلها لهذا
التطبيق هو ما عنده مانع انها تنتشر اصلا
ولكن هل بنتحدث عن انه هذا التطبيق عنده
اكسس على صورنا اللي احنا ما بدنا ننشرها
كمان
وممكن يستخدمها ولا بس اللي بنبعث له
بنرسلها او نرسلها للتطبيق لحتى يعدل
عليها
اذا رفع المستخدم صوره هي الصوره اللي
بيتم يعني نشرها واستخدامها ربما يتم حتى
اختراق التطبيق مستقبلا وجلب مثل هذه
الصور لكن الصور اللي في جهازك الخاص فيك
لن يتم الوصول لها لانه اجهزه الهواتف
الذكيه فيها من الحمايه يعني ما يسمح
بالشخص انه يعني مشاركه صور معينه هي من
من يتم رافعها على هذا التطبيق شكرا جزيلا
لك عبد العزيز الحمادي الخبير التقني كان
معنا من الرياض